[Música]
Estados Unidos autorizó la extradición a
Perú del expresidente Alejandro Toledo
quien es solicitado por la justicia
peruana por delitos relacionados con la
corrupción Toledo es acusado de haber
recibido cerca de 20 millones de dólares
en sobornos de odebrecht para favorecer
a la empresa con contratos de Obras
Públicas
el ex secretario de seguridad de México
Genaro García Luna fue declarado
culpable por cargos de narcotráfico la
justicia estadounidense declaró que
quien alguna vez estuvo a cargo de la
lucha contra los narcotraficantes
recibió millonarios sobornos del Cartel
De Sinaloa
se eleva a 46 el número de muertos por
las inundaciones y deslizamientos de
tierra que golpean el estado de Sao
Paulo en Brasil Mientras tanto continúa
la búsqueda de sobrevivientes y los
pronósticos indican que habrá más
lluvias en los próximos días
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú la fiscalía informó que Estados
Unidos concedió la extradición del
expresidente Alejandro Toledo requerido
en territorio peruano por delitos de
corrupción el exmandatario fue detenido
en 2019 en California y desde 2020 se
encuentra en arresto domiciliario debido
al brote de Kobe 19 concretamente Toledo
es acusado de recibir millonarios
sobornos de la empresa brasileña
odebrecht a cambio de favorecerla en sus
negocios en Perú cuando todavía era
presidente en el escándalo del
conglomerado brasileño también se han
visto implicados otros expresidentes
Alan García ollanta humala y Pedro Pablo
kuczynski se espera que Toledo se ha
trasladado pronto ya que el proceso de
extradición finalizó y no queda más
recursos por interponer
la fiscalía de la nación como autoridad
central en materia de extradiciones
informa que se ha tomado conocimiento
que el departamento de estado de los
Estados Unidos de América concedió la
extradición de Alejandro Toledo manrique
por los delitos de colusión y lavado de
activos
la corte Federal de Nueva York declaró
culpable al ex secretario de seguridad
de México Genaro García Luna por cargos
relacionados con narcotráfico es el
exfuncionario mexicano de más alto Rango
en ser juzgado por este tipo de delitos
a García Luna se le culpa de haber
recibido millonarios sobornos por parte
del Cartel De Sinaloa para permitir el
envío de droga a suelo estadounidense
hace 15 años Genaro García Luna era el
máximo responsable de seguridad de
México encargado de luchar contra los
cárteles de droga a sus 54 años acaba de
ser declarado culpable por un tribunal
de Nueva York por cargos relacionados
con el tráfico de drogas Genaro García
Luna secretario de seguridad pública de
México de 2006 a 2012 fue declarado
culpable hoy por un Jurado Federal en
Brooklyn y los cinco cargos de una
imputación formal que lo acusa de
participar en una continua empresa
criminal que incluye seis violaciones
relacionadas con narcotráfico
conspiración de distribución
internacional de cocaína conspiración
para poseer con intención de distribuir
cocaína conspiración para importar
cocaína y hacer declaraciones falsas
para el abogado de la ex funcionario
mexicano García Luna es víctima de la
venganza de narcos arrepentidos y de
acusaciones infundadas
estamos muy decepcionados por la
sentencia de hoy después de muchos años
de intentar construir contra el señor
García Luna compruebas creíbles y
fiables el gobierno ha tenido que
conformarse con un caso construido sobre
las espaldas de algunos de los
criminales más notorios y despiadados
para testificar en este tribunal
la caída de Genaro García Luna inició en
2019 durante el juicio contra Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán jefe del Cartel De Sinaloa
en el un narcotraficante explicó Cómo
había entregado millonarios sobornos a
García Luna nunca antes un funcionario
mexicano de tan alto Rango había sido
juzgado por este tipo de cargos en
Estados Unidos su condena fue aplaudida
por el gobierno del presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador cuyo
portavoz se pronunció en Twitter García
Luna es declarado culpable por tráfico
de drogas delincuencia organizada y
falsedad de declaraciones en Estados
Unidos la justicia ha llegado para Quien
fuera escudero de Felipe Calderón Los
crímenes en contra de nuestro pueblo no
serán olvidados nunca la con contra
García Luna se conocerá el 27 de junio
el ex secretario de seguridad pública
podría enfrentar una pena de entre 20
años hasta la cadena perpetua pasamos a
Chile porque continúa la emergencia por
los incendios forestales que azotaron al
centro y sur del país la alerta se fija
ahora en cuatro focos que se están
acercando zonas pobladas Uno de ellos es
el que está ubicado cerca a la comuna de
Santa Ana en la región del biobío según
las autoridades la expansión de las
llamas ha obligado a emitir órdenes de
evacuación en varias zonas hasta el
momento las conflagraciones en
territorio chileno han dejado 25 muertos
más de 7.000 personas sin hogar y cerca
de 450.000 hectáreas arrasadas desde
Santiago nuestra corresponsal Patricia
Luna nos ampliaba la información
los incendios que desde hace más de dos
semanas al centro sur de chile continúan
poniendo en aprietos a los más de 5.000
brigadistas desplegados en la zona entre
ellos varios centenares de brigadistas
internacionales países europeos como
Francia Portugal o España han enviado
ayuda Y también lo han hecho muchos
países de la región como Argentina
México o Venezuela entre muchos otros y
esto porque en las últimas horas se
reactivaron varios focos de incendios
que habían estado activos y que llegaron
a amenazar a poblaciones como la de
Santa Ana o también walkie Los Ángeles y
la ciudad de Coronel en una ciudad
bastante poblada que ha sido amenazada
por las llamas en varias ocasiones las
autoridades envían mensajes para
solicitar la evacuación de la población
pero no siempre los ciudadanos exceden a
hacerlo muchos de ellos se resisten ante
el miedo de abandonar sus posesiones Y
que estas sean arrebatadas por lo que la
zona opera un toque de queda son casi
450.000 hectáreas según los balances
preliminares las que ya han sido
arrasadas por las llamas en unos
incendios que dejan también un triste
saldo de 25 personas fallecidas mientras
el debate sobre la intencionalidad de
los fuegos sigue bastante álgido Aunque
en las últimas horas publicó un estudio
que afirma que las investigaciones
técnicas de un total de 650 incendios
atribuyen tan solo un 25% de ellos a una
posible intencionalidad el debate sigue
muy presente entre la ciudadanía y
también entre la política chilena
el gobierno del Estado de Sao Paulo
anunció que el número de muertos por las
Fuertes lluvias e inundaciones aumentó a
46 otras 2500 personas fueron
desplazadas por los daños y actualmente
se encuentran sin hogar la mayoría de
Los afectados Espera que continúe el
envío de ayuda Estatal y federal para
hacer frente a la emergencia entre tanto
los meteorólogos informan que el
pronóstico indica que habrá más lluvias
en los próximos días
las autoridades no han escatimado
esfuerzos en la búsqueda de
desaparecidos la maquinaria pesada
retira grandes troncos y excava en medio
del lodo para despejar el camino que
conecta al Estado de Río de Janeiro con
la ciudad portuaria de santos en el
estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil
la cifra de muertos y personas
desaparecidas sigue en aumento producto
de las inundaciones y deslizamientos de
tierra que iniciaron el fin de semana un
suceso que ocurrió justo cuando un gran
grupo de turistas acudían en masa a las
playas durante el feriado anual del
carnaval en una zona turística que
frecuentan las personas adineradas que
buscan estar alejados de las fiestas
callejeras masivas en las grandes
ciudades
había un ruido fuerte Entonces mi hijo
fue a verlo y cuando llegó mi balcón ya
se había caído y estaba rompiendo la
pared nuestra salvación fue la
curiosidad de mi hijo de ir a mirar de
lo contrario estaríamos todos muertos
Y aunque 7,5 toneladas de artículos de
ayuda con alimentos agua y kits de
higiene ya se han distribuido entre las
víctimas según el gobierno local
1730 personas han sido desplazadas y más
de 800 quedaron sin hogar y mientras las
fuerzas armadas se han unido para la
búsqueda de desaparecidos se espera que
la Marina sume esfuerzos de Socorro a
partir del jueves ganaremos refuerzos en
la atención sanitaria a los heridos con
la llegada de un barco de la marina de
Brasil Que funcionará como hospital de
campaña con hasta 300 camas de
enfermería y con profesionales de
ortopedia psiquiatría traumatología y
medicina en general
las recientes inundaciones se suman a
una serie de desastres de este tipo que
han golpeado a Brasil en los últimos
años analistas apuntan que mientras la
calidad de la construcción en las
laderas no se mejore este escenario
podría seguirse repitiendo en temporada
de lluvias
en Colombia de acuerdo con el alto
comisionado de paz Danilo Rueda el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro espera
comenzar negociaciones con los dos
grupos disidentes de la extinta
guerrilla de las Farc en las próximas
semanas la iniciativa hace parte del
proyecto de paz total de Petro y según
el alto funcionario La idea es que
ningún grupo se quede por fuera ahora
que ya reiniciaron las conversaciones
con la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación nacional Rueda mencionó que
esperan concretar pronto un cese el
fuego bilateral con el Ln grupo ilegal
con el que actualmente adelanta una
segunda Ronda de conversaciones de paz
en México
y terminamos con información deportiva
porque Haití dio la sorpresa y se impuso
a Chile en la primera final del
repechaje para el mundial femenino de
fútbol que se disputará en Australia y
Nueva Zelanda A mediados de año el
conjunto caribeño venció a las australes
en la ciudad de Oakland e hizo historia
al clasificar por primera vez a una fase
final de copa mundo chile frustra su
objetivo de completar dos
participaciones seguidas a la Magna cita
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]